hey what's up my name's Samuel leaves on
the property investor and the fact that
you're watching this probably means that
your property investor - or maybe you're
on your way to becoming the property
investor that's why I run this channel
the reason that people aren't further on
in life because one in business it's
simply just because of lack of knowledge
is lack of knowledge so what's the thing
that's holding you back
comment below with your question and
guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna answer
your question next week so comment like
crazy below also smash the like button
if you like these videos and of course
don't forget to subscribe
turn the notification belt on and then
that way what I'll do next week's videos
you'll get a ping and then you'll be
able to watch and hopefully you'll have
your question answered let's see what
we've got we've got a guy called G
Stephen Kemp who says boom thank you in
advance for answering this question for
this community yeah we've got a picture
question Samuel what are your sentiments
around utilizing tenant buyers to boost
your buy-to-let cash flow Walt's also
helping first-time buyers onto the
property ladder geez Stephen I love
tenant buyers I think tenant buyers are
a brilliant brilliant model and
something that I really really encourage
and do endorse for anyone that doesn't
know what tenant buyer is it's when when
you move someone into your house but you
instead of charging them 500 pound rent
and and again you can negotiate this it
depends but I'll give you an it I'll
give you an example so instead of
charging five in Japan when you say look
pay 400 pound rent but then give me an
additional four hundred pound so you're
giving me eight hundred pounds but 400
pound that's going to be rent but four
in Japan of that is going to be going
towards you one day buying the property
that's why it's good tenant buyer so
they live in the property but they the
idea is that they'll want a buy it and
the reason it's so great is because it
gives people normal people that can't
afford to buy a property they have the
option to buy the properties they're put
in 400 pound a month in this example
aside down the line there'll be a point
in time maybe in five years or seven
years where they'll have the option to
buy it but all that all those little
four hundred pounds
that'll be like the deposit and then the
rest on top of the mortgage and it's a
lot better than the help to buy help to
buy government schemes that is a proper
way of helping people get on the ladder
not only does it help those people to
get on the ladder it's also great for
the landlords because if you've got
someone living in your house and they're
giving you 800 pound a month rent well
that's really good
cash flow so you're gonna yes you're
going to be selling it down the line but
you fixed the price now you fix the
points that you all be happy with
they're happy with you get a really good
cash flow right now and tenant buyers
they don't need any management they
don't cause any issues because they're
going to be buying the house anything
that needs fixing or changing they'll do
themself it's a whole different mindset
so they really really encourage that
kind of setup and I think it's great so
that's my answer what else we got
Danny Danny says do you have any tips or
resources you recommend for people
undergoing their first renovation
project I'd have any experience in doing
this and a very little knowledge in this
domain so I feel it's one of the main
risk areas you correct the risks are
buying a bad house or in a bad area
having bad tenants or having bad
builders and and going over on the
refurb overtime scout over budget my
advice on this Danny would probably be
to get a survey on the property before
you buy it and a survey will tell you
roughly what needs to be done on the
house so if there's some damp work that
needs to be done if there's a leaky roof
they'll the survey would do that and the
reason I get a professional survey done
by a chartered surveyor is because
they're not going to be su or try and
pull the wool over your eyes because
they can't do that legally where there's
a lot of builders they'll come out hell
oh you know this leaves this and this
and this they'll charge you a lot extra
so get a survey and then bring that
survey to a team of builders or three
different builders and say how much
would you cost to do this and make them
give you a very itemized breakdown of
exactly what they're gonna do exactly
how much they're going to charge make
them give you a time scale of how long
it's gonna take
put a penalty in place if they go over
the time scale so you can do it even if
you've got no experience and if you're
not a builder yourself or something to
do before you can do it if you do it
properly not all simple which I'm
venturing with someone partnering with
someone that has got a bit more
experience in this area
also don't take on a massive renovation
project if you've never done it before
start small and work up so that with my
general advice I wish you all the best
and good luck in your projects what else
we got her NAB says hi Samuel I'm a
foreigner Sweden citizen fantastic great
to have you watching the channel
I just got approved for a UK buy to let
mortgage
fantastic double good news do you have
any tips and tricks for non UK residents
investing in the UK property market yeah
what I would say is you want to make
money in property but you also want to
make money if you can in doing the
transfer presumably have to transfer
money from Sweden over to the UK now by
the way I'm not speaking from experience
because I am a UK citizen so I'm only
speaking from what I know about some of
my students that have got to do this so
that's my disclaimer I'm not I'm not
Swedish
so when what I would suggest is don't
wait until you you need to transfer the
money over because what will happen is
you've got your mortgage approved
you're now going to find your house you
put your off when it be accepted and
then suddenly the solicitor will say we
need your money now and if that happens
you might have to end up transferring
money over when when the exchange is bad
and you'll lose money on the exchange so
I'll say is if you're a foreign
investment vesting in the UK is you've
got your mortgage approved fantastic
wait and move you money over now or wait
until the exchange is good so you're in
favor and then move the money over and
then you can just relax the money is
there the money's ready and then when
you actually need to use it bank is just
there it's ready in the UK so that comma
general advice also make sure if you're
investing in the UK you need really good
people in the UK you need a good
management team in place it's gonna be
doing builders you need good you need a
good people in place because you can't
be going back and forth but ultimately
you've got to invest behind the money is
and if the money is in the UK and you're
in Sweden I don't know much about Sweden
I don't know much about the property
market in Sweden but I respect you for
investing in the UK because sometimes
people think I've only got to invest in
my country I can only invest in my
village and actually you got to invest
where the money is and ultimately if
this is going to be giving you a passive
income anyway you need to be able to
systemize it so I've got properties in
Wales I've got them in England and I
wouldn't I would buy in Scotland but it
doesn't matter where the properties are
what matters because there's systemized
what matters is that it's making me
money so respect I wish you all the best
in that and if you have any follow-up
questions drop them on this video not to
announce the next week as well okay
Marcus Marcus Blackwood after the crash
course in London I'm trying to find
ready to rent HMOs cities to get their
ball rolling what advice would you give
to someone who
lives in the centre of London and needs
to research cities up north Marcus I
wouldn't necessarily say that just
because you're in London you have to
research it he's up north because you
know there's loads of people that come
through the crash course I mean up
getting rent to rents in I guess it's up
north a little bit but Oxford I don't
know if you saw I'm just deny a witness
Wednesday with a lady called Stella and
she lives in the centre of London she's
killing it in Oxford she's making four
and a half thousand pound a month with
rent to rent in Oxford so I wouldn't
necessarily go really really far up
north you don't even have to go
vertically up north at all I mean the
centre centre of London might be tricky
but there's so many areas on the
outskirts of London that works super
well for rent HMOs and also because it's
rent to hate you know you're not
actually buying anything so the fact
that the prices are really high doesn't
matter because you're only renting them
anyway you're taking control of them
what matters is that you've got that
good monthly cash flow so that's my
general advice I hope that helps okay
burning desire I know you burning desire
you've asked questions before is it
better to get a few seventy thousand
pound houses where there's limited
growth but decent rental yield or save
up more and get a 30,000 pound I don't
know what that means maybe it's supposed
to mean for him mm where yields are
lower but there's plenty of room for
growth like in five years of purchase
burning desire just because a house is
cheap doesn't mean that there's no room
for growth I think if you buy in London
right now and you buy and Liverpool
right now you're going to have more
growth percentage over the next three
years in Liverpool than you would in
London so don't think that just because
it's expensive it's gonna have more
growth that's not the case there'll be
more growth in the sense of profit but
the percentage is no I don't believe
that I think if you want to get growth
you just need to look look at what
previously has been full because a
growth will always follow a recession
so where's never been a recession by
there then there's going to be an
expansion expansion recession recession
expansion but overall over time
properties go up that's like my mantra
so nationally you'll gain a good profit
of cash flow every single month on your
property period the return on investment
needs to be good don't talk he'll and
stop talking about growth in expensive
areas
not the case okay next Matt backs Matt
backs Matt backs has been to the crash
course from Australia
I remember this dude good to see you
still I'm coming on on YouTube I hope
you're still caring I know you've done
some deals and stuff good job let's see
what he says
when developing a personal brand what
are the three core values that you hope
your audience will associate yourself
with the three core values if your start
if you're starting out and you want to
build a personal brand on me I guess
it's the same buddy okay firstly
transparency you want to be known for
being a transparent person honest don't
try and pretend you're doing things
you're not doing don't try to pretend
anything this whole fake it till you
make it think I don't agree with that at
all I think that actually you've just
got to be authentic and say this is what
I'm doing this is what I've done and and
be totally honest and transparent not
just not just transparent about yourself
but also direct and honest with other
people as well the second thing would be
what value would be doing what you say
do what you say you said you were gonna
do the way you said when you said how
you said it and just build a reputation
for that for over delivering and under
promising for being someone of your work
really born and then thirdly value I
would say as cheesy as this sounds I
would say just be someone of love like
do what you're doing because you
genuinely care about people and when you
have a good heart and the other heart to
genuinely help people the money will
follow
for sure so just love people love
yourself and there'll be my three things
hope that helped if you enjoy this video
smash the light boy keep commenting your
questions I'm gonna answer one more
question Danny Danny
Abdallah hi Samuel thanks again for all
the valuable insights you provide you're
so welcome smash the light barn I'm
based at working full-time in London
sounds like I've got a lot of people
that watch my YouTube either from London
or from overseas where all the
northerners where are they but looking
to invest in my first buy to that
property further away giving lower
prices and higher rental yields make
sense I'm happy to invest further away
and have but have a few concerns
including building up our team in that
location and how I could successfully
manage a renovation managed builders
while being far away do you have any
tips regarding this and do you recommend
any areas that are within easy act
up to two hours away to London that are
good for investments thank you
okay Danny um good investment areas
within a couple hours of London I would
say Birmingham Birmingham is great also
they're bringing article four into
Birmingham it this year in June so if
you can buy a house now and if you're
doing renovations turn it into a HMO
you'll get automatic grandfather rights
planning permission and you'll see the
value go up a lot so Birmingham was
really good I think if you want to be
involved in hands-on you're probably
smart in saying I'm happy to travel a
bit a couple of hours if you do
something in Newcastle you know it's
gonna be really really really tricky to
get there long term
once it's all set up then you've done it
and you're renting it out you should
never have to go and visit the property
ever if you're starting out and you
wanted to do reverbs and stuff like that
I think I think you're on the right path
Troy Birmingham out have a look see what
you find guys that's it for today I hope
you enjoyed the video if you want more
and let me know by subscribing and
smashing the like button also don't
forget to comment your questions I'm
gonna do another video just like this
next Sunday
just click on that right there that's
the thing that's the thing you need to
click on click on it come down meet me
even if you're not sure what you want to
do or not at least click on it and have
a look don't forget to subscribe over
here as well thank you so much take it
have a look Stella look I'll see you
there god bless thank you so much
you
[Music]